well the Trump riots have hit Brazil as
insurrectionists are committing very
similar sorts of acts as what we saw on
January 6 2021 in the United States
demanding the return of former president
jair bolsonaro who is in Florida having
chicken at KFC and walking around a
Publix Supermarket I I know I know we
are going to get to all of it but when
we say the actions of trump and his
cronies following the 2020 election
in part due to the lack of consequences
that they suffered will encourage and
will normalize the same type of behavior
in other places and that is exactly what
we are now seeing in Brazil the
Associated Press reports Pro bolsonaro
rioters storm Brazil's top government
offices we have Incredible video of All
Sorts and it looks like January 6th it
it is a version of January 6 which we
will get to
um AP reporting supporters of former
Brazilian president bolsonaro who
refused to accept his election defeat
stormed Congress you could just replace
Trump and Trump supporters there the
Supreme Court and the presidential
Palace on Sunday a week after the
inauguration of his leftist rival
president Lula thousands of
demonstrators bypassed security
barricades climbed on roofs smashed
windows and invaded all three buildings
which were believed to be largely vacant
on the weekend some of the demonstrators
called for a military intervention wow
where we have we heard that before to
either restore the far-right bolsonaro
to power or oust Lula from the
presidency hours went by before control
of the buildings on brasilia's vast
three powers Square was re-established
with hundreds of the participants
arrested and we're going to talk about
that as well
in a news conference from Sao Paulo Lula
accused bolsonaro of encouraging the
uprising by those he termed fascist
Fanatics and he read a freshly signed
decree for the federal government to
take control of security in the federal
district saying quote there is no
precedent for what they did and these
people need to be punished let's take a
look at some of the stunning stunning
video here is one in which you will see
and let's see if I can get the volume
right
will keep the volume lower in this one
you see folks who have gotten through
the police barricade you quite literally
see the fencing there down on the ground
invaded the Congress ramp they
threatened to occupy the chamber and the
Senate which they subsequently did they
subsequently did these videos different
setting uh different weather that's for
sure but looking very very much like
January 6th here in the United States in
another video continuing to look just
like what we saw on January 6 the
bolsonaristas invaded the floor of the
federal Senate and they're wearing
different clothes you don't see the Q
Anon shaman
but you see a very very similar looking
event as to what we saw on January 6th
in the House of Representatives
[Music]
yeah
the imagery as we continue looking here
is more imagery where you will see and
I'm trying to get the audio mix just
right so you can hear me
this looks like January 6th they have
Flags they approach police they knock
down the barriers in this case police
take out some kind of an irritant spray
it appears
but the Riders uh overwhelmed the police
in the sense that they break the barrier
and they continue moving on into the
buildings
where have we seen this before I mean it
is just another example of the same
thing again now it is really important
to understand
not only how can I say this
in a general sense we know where they
got this idea we know where they got
this idea because we saw it here on
January 6 2021 it's been two years and
three days since that took place but
it's also important to understand
that Bannon Steve Bannon and other Trump
aides were advising jair bolsonaro in
November about how to proceed this is an
article I have on the screen from The
Washington Post the date is November
23rd and we're going to deal with this
in more detail a little bit later
Trump AIDS Bannon Miller advising the
bolsonaros on next steps next steps what
do you mean well you know instigator
Riot an Insurrection some allies and
advisors writes the article want the
Brazilian president to contest his
election loss to Lula others want a
global fight over free speech and you
can read this and we're going to look at
it a little bit more later so I won't
delve into it that much right now but
this is the Playbook they helped them
develop the Playbook and we should not
be surprised when the same inputs give
you very similar outputs now what is
necessary here
is for the military to say
that they unconditionally support Lula
as the legally elected president and you
all know I absolutely despise bolsonaro
and I'm not a big fan of Lula I've I've
told you my issues with Lula before I
think Lula is better than bolsonaro but
that's a separate question from who is
the legally elected president and the
legally elected president is Lula so the
military and maybe by the time we go to
air with this it will have happened I
don't know if it has as of right now it
hasn't happened which is why I'm saying
it the military should say Lula's the
legal president don't come to us for any
sort of ideas about a coup or help with
the Insurrection Lula is the president
period now unfortunately there are many
in the Brazilian military who are very
much anti-lula and when you know that
that's the case until you hear that
unconditional statement of support you
wonder whether it's actually coming this
is in part what happens when the people
who tried this here weren't seriously
punished and by by that I mean the
instigators and the agitators I know Q
Anon Shaman got four years or whatever I
get it
but big picture all the way up to Trump
the people who created this environment
and stimulated exactly what went down
they have not been punished so so this
is what happens one difference arguably
that we're already seeing is that the
mass arrests have started in Brazil now
are they fully capturing all the law
Breakers yet we don't know but scores
have already been arrested after they
showed up and they did this the things
that I showed you doing on show them
doing on video
um and while there were of course
eventually hundreds of arrests here in
the United States at the immediate time
there was not that show of we're
arresting all of you and throwing you
all on a bus and quite literally that's
what's been happening with a lot of
these rioters who quite frankly are
terrorists
um in Brazil and so that's a difference
we'll see if we get a statement from the
military and we'll see where this
ultimately shakes out now in the midst
of all this you might be wondering David
where is
scenaro well he's in Florida eating
chicken at KFC and looking around at a
Publix and that is exactly what I want
to talk about next did you know that
half of Americans are deficient in
vitamin A vitamin C and magnesium most
Americans are deficient in vitamin D I
take vitamin D during the winter it is
sometimes difficult to eat exactly the
right amount of each food to get exactly
what you need I just make my life
simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens in
the morning one scoop of ag1 I get the
entire day's worth of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients it's what I want it's no
more it's no less it's not making any
outlandish claims it's just an easy
sustainable routine I've tried different
ways of taking vitamins ag1 is cheaper
it's quicker it's tastier I'm not
fumbling around with different capsules
it tastes great to drink straight with
water sometimes I'll put it in a
smoothie or Shake it's simple it's
something easy you can do going into the
new year staying properly nourished
athletic greens is giving my audience a
free year supply of vitamin D I take
that every day in Winter plus you'll get
five free travel packs of ag1 go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below